jean lopez est ce que l'allemagne il
japon d'ailleurs avec une chance de
gagner là la seconde guerre mondiale on
peut en douter
soixante quinze ans après oui c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire très honnêtement
je pense que ça n'était pas possible de
quelques façons comprennent le problème
n'ont pas n'ont pas la surface
nécessaire non pas n'a pas le potentiel
nécessaire le temps que leurs preuves le
temps que l'allemagne mobilisent à fond
son potentiel militaire ce qui va lui
demander juste d'attendre jusqu'en 1943
il est trop tard parce que pendant ce
temps là ses adversaires eux ont appris
à faire la guerre
en gros si vous voulez de 1939 à 1942
on a une situation qui voit l'allemagne
se battre avec un potentiel industriel
relativement limitées mais elle elle
sait faire la guerre elle a compris ce
que c'est que ce qu'une guerre de
mouvement moderne
elle a donc un avantage opérationnel
incontestable de leur côté ses
adversaires commencent à faire leur
gigantesque potentiel industriel et
humain et ils apprennent ils apprennent
de leurs erreurs
l'armée anglaise de 1942 celle de
l'allemagne
elle est bien meilleure que celle de
1940 l'armée soviétique de stalingrad
n'était évidemment pas l'armée
soviétique de juin 1941
c'est aussi vrai des américains ces
mêmes vrai des forces françaises qui
continuent la lutte sous le drapeau du
général de gaulle
elle se bat mieux que les généraux de 40
donc là ça n'est ça n'était pas de
quelques façons comprennent le problème
je ne vois pas comment à moins de
pousser les uchronies met alors à ce
moment-là avec les avec les ici on fait
dire tout ce qu'on veut à l'histoire on
n'est plus dans le domaine de l'histoire
mais je ne vois vraiment pas comment
c'était possible pour eux ça se ça se
reflète dans les décisions stratégiques
d'hitler hitler n'arrête pas de se
tromper de ce point de vue là en 39 il
pense qu'une fois la pologne écarté il
va peut-être pouvoir se rabibocher avec
les occidentaux
après il est certain que une fois que la
france sera
à terre les anglais vont demander la
paix ça il en est sûr il n'a pas arrêté
de le répéter à ses généraux rien du
tout churchill continuer le combat
après ils pensent que 6,6 l'écrasent
l'armée rouge s'il va jusqu'à moscou
seniors ce métier qui va s'effondrer
non là non plus ça n'a pas marché ces
plans stratégiques parce qu'ils sont
fondés sur des assertions qui sont
fausses vont s'effondrer les uns après
les autres et c'est encore plus vrai des
japonais pensaient que les japonais
attaquent à pearl harbor le 6 et 7
décembre 1941 et que le 6 mai 1942
cinq mois plus tard ils ont déjà perdu
l'essentiel de leurs porte avions
pendant la bataille de midway
pour eux le rêve n'aura duré que cinq
mois c'était une véritable folie quand
on produit 7 millions de tonnes d'acier
de s'attaquer à un géant comme les
etats-unis qui en produit 92 millions de
tonnes
c'était pas possible quand on arrive à
fabriquer 100 mille automobiles par an
comme c'est le cas du japon de se
mesurer avec un pays qui est capable
d'en sortir 10 millions là rien de jouer
en leur faveur et dès 1942 et 43 les
allemands comme les japonais vont être
littéralement submergés sous un matériel
de qualité servie par des officiers qui
sont deux de meilleur en meilleur avec
le temps qui passe
non je pense que il est absolument vain
de vouloir de vouloir traiter cette
uchronie là est ce que le reich et japon
auraient pu gagner la seconde guerre
mondiale
[Musique]